طالبات جاكي فروزن رئيسه وفد اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي بعدم اشراق ممثلين عن حزب
العظم اليهوديه وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه في
الاجتماعات التي يعقدها الوفد اثناء
زيارته لاسرائيل وتتزامن الزياره مع تاكيد
ممثلين وقناصله من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
اثناء زيارتهم المسجد الاقصى على ضروره
الحفاظ على الوضع القانوني والتاريخي
القائمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان اذا كان خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الرسائل
الامريكيه من استثناء ممثلين عن احزاب
اليمنيه المتطرفه من حضور اجتماعات وفد
مجلس الشيوخ خلال زيارته لاسرائيل وما مدى
تاثير الزيارات الوفود الاوروبيه
والمناشدات الامميه للحفاظ على الوضع
القائم بالاقصى وهل ستنعكس على سلوك
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تجاه المقدسات في ظل
الاستمرار ممارسات الاحتلال الاستفزازيه
كان اخرها كانوا السفير الاردني من دخول
المسجد وهل ستشهد المرحله المقبله مزيدا
من الضغوط الدوليه على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه عبر التلميح بعدم الرغبه في
التعامل مع اعضاءها المتطرفين وكيف سيرتد
ذلك على المشهد السياسي الداخلي في
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
لا تمر نياته وسياساته حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو بشان المسجد الاقصى دون ان تثير
صدا دوليا هنا وهناك في ظل تصاعدي ممارسات
اليمين الاسرائيلي المتطرف والتي وصلت
طورا المتقدمه باقتحام وصفه من قبل وزير
الامن الاثمار بن جرير لباحات الاقصى مات
السؤال اكثر من ملحن بشان المدى الذي تريد
الحكومه التي توصف بالاكثر يمينيه وتطرفا
في تاريخ اسرائيل ان تاخذ اليه الوضع
القانوني والتاريخي للمسجد الاقصى اضافه
الى الرساله التي تضمنها موقف الوفد
الامريكي باستبعاد اي لقاء لاعضائه
لممثلين عن حزبي العظمه اليهوديه
والصهيونيه الدينيه فقد كان اللقاء بين 25
ممثلا وقنصلا من الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وغيرها مع مسؤولين في دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه مناسبه شددوا فيها على عدم
المساسب الاقصى وتفادي اي افعاله من شانها
تصعيد موقفي في القدس وسائر الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
الاوضاع في الشرق الاوسط مثلت محور
اجتماعا لمجلس الامن تم خلاله استعراضه
مختلف التطورات التي تصاعدت خاصه بعد
تشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده بقياده
بنيامنه نياهو ضمن شراكه له مع احزاب
اليمنيه المتطرفه وفيما قدم مندوب فلسطين
لدى الامم المتحده جردا بما تقترفه
الحكومه والقوات الاسرائيليه بحق
الفلسطينيين وحقوقهم موقعه همم موقعه
موقعه بينهم مزيدا من الشهداء والجرحى
اكتفى وماثله اسرائيل باعتبار ما يقال عن
تصرفاته حكومه
مجرد مسرحيه واكاذيب وتزوير للواقع منتقدا
من يقبلها بما في ذلك الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا موضوع معنا من عمان معين طاهر
الكاتب والبحر الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
هل ستعود تلك العلاقه التي لم تكن في احسن
احوالها في عهد اوباما بين الرئيس
واي فاي
بالتاكيد هذه تعتبر اوقات جديده في
العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه لان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تتخذ خطوات تؤدي الى
قلق شديد
داخليا وحتى اسرائيل لذلك
يحصل على التقييم حول ما هي رؤيتهم لبعض
المواضيع التي تهمل الولايات المتحده مثل
موضوع عن الفلسطيني ايران وما تريد ان
تقوم به الحكومه الجديده في الديمقراطيه
وايضا هم ايونات الوفد ايضا كلهم الرئيس
بان الحكومه الجديده
الى زياده التوتر
داخل اسرائيل هذا هو هدف هذه الزياره وهو
فاهم بالضبط ما هو موقف والعين التوجه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
حسنا الان يعني ماذا يمكن ان نقول ان انها
دلالات ورسائل الموقف موقف ولايه الوفد
الامريكي مثلا الذي طالب بعد عدم اشراك اي
ممثلين من احزان من حزبين يعتبرهما
متطرفين العظمه وسجونيه الدينيه السؤال
يعني
وهؤلاء قالوا ان هذين الرئيسي
لا ينبغي ان يكون جزء من اجتماع وهذا مؤشر
هنا في الولايات المتحده اليهوديه هنا
يمثل ما يهودون التحقيق داخل اسرائيل ومع
الفلسطينيين وهذه يعني
احمر قد يؤثر على العلاقات بين البلدين
وبالتالي هذه المؤشر وذو مغزى مهم جدا صار
معين كيف تلقى الفلسطينيون همم ما طلبه
سواء الوفد الامريكي او ايضا ووفود همم من
الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني انا انا اظن ان علينا ان ندرك
باهيه خصائص حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وما هو
التحالف الذي اجراه مع الصهيونيه
الدينيه هنالك متغير رئيس يحدث الان في في
اسرائيل ربما للمره الاولى حيث
تتشابك او تتكامل الروايه الثورهيه مع
الرؤيا همم
السياسيه وهذا بلا شك سيكون له تاثير كبير
على مجمل الاحداث ليس فقط على الفلسطينيين
كما اشار ضيفك كامل واشنطن وانما ايضا حتى
على الوضع الداخلي في في اسرائيل نحن نشهد
منذ ايام مظاهرات بعشرات الالاف من يهود
وهم صهاينه بالمناسبه يعني ليسوا من
اليسار الاسرائيلي همم فحسب ولكن ايضا من
فئه من اليمين الذين يحتاجون حتى على هذه
الحكومه
لمسائل تتعلق بالديمقراطيه وبالحريات
وبالقضاء وهذا ينعكس ايضا على اليهود في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعلى انصار
اسرائيل في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فالمساله في الحقيقه متشابكه ومتداخله هي
اكثر حتى من الجانب من الموضوع الفلسطيني
فحسب على اهميه الموضوع همم فلسطيني انا
اظن فيما يتعلق بالموضوع الفلسطيني ان
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي طيله
الفتره الماضيه
كانوا دوما ينادوا بحل ال- همم او دولهتين
ولكن هذه المناداه كانت في الحقيقه مناداه
شكليه لم تقوم الادارات الامريكيه
المتتابعه باي جهد او لتحقيق هذا الحل لم
تقوم باي جهد لوقف الاستيطان تحت الزوبعه
عندما انشاء مستوطنه جديده ولكنها تختفي
وتبقى المستقبل في هذه الزوعه الزوبعه
وتبقى المستوطنه المفاوضات الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه متوقفه منذ اكثر من سبعه
اعوام نعم لا يوجد اي افق سياسي اريد تقوم
به الحكومه الحاليه هو هو يعني همم
انهاء القضيه الفلسطينيه وفق رؤيتها
الثوره
المتحده طيب
الولايات المتحده انت تقول هذا يخيف
الولايات المتحده وانا اسال جويل الان هذا
الوفد الامريكي
لا يمثل حزبا بعينه هذا الوقت الذي ترثه
جمهوري وايضا الديمقراطي الى اي ماده يمكن
القول ان يعني موقفه يمثل موقف الحكومه
الامريكيه همم الاداره الامريكيه تجاه
حكومه المياه وتركيبتها
حاره
بالتاكيد يمثلون
الاداره الامريكيه من حيث القضايا
السياسيه التي تناقش الموضوع على فلسطين
وفلسطين على ايران لكن يتعلق الامر في
وجهه نظر الكونجرس وهؤلاء المشرعون يمثلون
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وليس هناك بانك قلق
شديد داخل المجلس الشيوخ
حول تجاه الحكومه
الاسرائيلي حاليا الا تقود الديمقراطيه
والعين
استاذ معين الى اي ماده يرسم هذا الموقف
مسافه بين مكونات الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بمعنى هل المشكله في حزبين فقط ام ان
التركيبه كلها لها موقف يمكن وصفه
بالمتطرف جدا
كثيرا عن
موقف
صهيونيه الدينيه او الحزبين اليمنيين
هنالك اعضاء في الكود حزب نتنياهو واشد
يمينيه حتى من ثمار
ولكن الفارق ان احدهما يعني يضع
قفاز من الحرير فوق القفاز الحديد الذي
الذي يرتدي لا يوجد على الاطلاق في تقدير
انا موقف نتنياه هو يعني يتقن دور اللعبه
السياسيه بطريقه افضل هؤلاء متمسكون بنصوص
ثوراتيه بنصوص تاريخيه بشعبويه يعني عامه
لذلك يعني كما شاهدنا في زيارته مثلا
زياره ثمار للمسجد الاقصى يعني فقط كان
يسعى وراء الشعبيه وراء الادعاء انه يقوم
بتحقيق
في لا يوجد هنالك فارق على المستوى
الاستراتيجي ما بين ال ال نتنياهو ما بين
حلوجود
وهل يوجد فارغ روبن في ما يمكن توقعه
توقعه من الاداره الامريكيه في همم الفتره
المقبله وسوف تكون هناك نعلم زياره لجيك
سوليفان وامور من هذا النوع هل يعني بمعنى
المناسبات الامريكيه هذه وغيرها هل تكفي
لايقاف ما يقوم به
المتطرفون في الحكومه الاسرائيليه تجاه
الاقصى والاراضي الفلسطينيه
الاوقات صعبه جدا هذا الوقت لانه يبدو ان
حكومه نتنيها تريد ان تقوم بحركتها الاولى
بتغيير والمحكمه العليا وخلق الظروف
بحيثنا الكنيسه البرلماني سطيه ان يتجاوز
قرارات المحكمه العليا وهذا هو مساله
داخليه ولكن هذه محكمه تحمي حقوق
الفلسطينيين عندما تكون هناك مشاكل عندما
تقوم الحكومه الاسرائيليه باجراءاتنا عمال
مثلا في المستوطنات بحيث التي تعترض عليها
الاسراء الفلسطينيون في توجهنا الى
المحاكم اذن هذا في مجال بعد همم
الامريكيه تتحدث عن ذلك وعن قضيه
طهران وموضوع
اتفاقات ومعاهده ابراهام لكن ما يصير
اهميه حاليا هو موضوع نوع القوانين ستصدر
هذه الحكومه فيما يتعلق بالم كما
الديمقراطيه والمحكمه العليا وكما قال
الضيف الاخر 10,000 من الاسرائيلين يحتجون
في الشوارع يوم امس محكمه العليا في سرايا
قالت ان احد الوزراء ايرندير لا ينبغي
يكون جزء من الحكومه لانه متهم بالفساد
وبالتالي هناك امكانيه ان تكون هناك ازمه
دستوريه داخل اسرائيل في الايام القادمه
بينها العامل القانوني القضائي المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه كما ذكر جولي اصدرت
قرارا يقضي بمنع الزعيم حركه شاشه
وزاريه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه والتي يشغل
فيها حاليا حقيبتي الداخليه والصحه وكان
درعين بيتهم التهرب الضريبي واجبر على
اعتزال الحياه السياسيه ثم تم التوصل الى
صفقه معه تجنبه السجن الفعلي في القضيه
همم معين قرار المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه
الى اي ماده هو مهم وماذا يعني بالنسبه
للفلسطيني
يعني هناك في الحقيقه وتفقد ان اشير الى
ملاحظه قالها ضيفك من واشنطن وهي ان
الفلسطينيين يلجئون الى المحكمه العليا
وانها تحميه من الاستيطان هذا غير صحيح
على الاطلاق المحكمه العليا في كل
قراراتها حتى الان لم تقم لم تقم بذلك هي
تشرع يعني وتساهم في تشريع الاستيطان وهي
محكمه منحازه في هذا المجال فيما يتعلق
بقرار اليوم وقرار يتعلق بمحاربه الاتجاه
الذي يقوده نتنياهو بالاساس ليس لحمايه
الدرع وانما لحمايه هو شخصيا في المستقبل
من حيث تحجيم القضاء وهذه احدى الخلافات
الموجوده في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ملاحظه اخرى او يبدا يشير اليها او
ملاحظتين سريعتين في الحقيقه الملاحظه
الاولى ان السفير الامريكي اليوم في
اسرائيل همم قال بانه لا ينوي مقاطعه ايون
من اعضاء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يعني لذلك يعني انا لا اعتقد
انه يجب ميل مساله همم قرار لجنه الشيوخ
بعدم مقابله هذه من الحزبين اكثر مما
ينبغي
وكذلك ايضا اود ان اشير الى ان هذه اللجنه
التي تدور هي لجنه همم انشئت لتاييد
الاتفاقات الابراهيميه ومن هنا ياتي الخوف
الامريكي وخوف حتى هذه اللجنه من ان تؤدي
خطوات نتنياهو الى يعني مزيد من ال- ال-
ال- التوتر الى التفجير الاوضاع هم
يحاولون ان ان ان يحافظوا على الوضع كما
هو همم وفي ذلك الوقت يستمر الاستيطان
ويستمر قدم الارض الفلسطيني دون ان تصل
الامور الى نقطه تفجير ما يخيفهم في ثمار
الدينيه هو ان هؤلاء يسرعون في ايصال
الاوضاع الى نقاط تفجير طيب هل لدي واشنطن
افكار محدده نريد مناقشتها مع هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مطالب
ده ده امس يكفي يعني
سيكتفي الاداره الامريكيه بالمناسبات كما
قلت
وبدعوات التهدئه والتعقل وما الى ذلك من
الامور
ان يكون واضح عنه ان المحاكم هي التي تدخل
وترفض اجراءات الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
المستوطنات للتعرض عليها الفلسطينيون كل
ما تسمح لهم فرصه وهذا ما تقوم به الحكومه
المحكمه وهذا ما هو حكومه وهذا سيكون
مشكله وهذا ما اعتقد ان السلف ان ان
سيحاول ان هو بثير الحكومه حل للدولتين هو
الهدف هو التذكير الحكومه نتنيها بان
الدبلوماسيه فيما يتعلق بايران معه قوه
ايضا هدف لجاب الطرق نوافذ مفتوحه
في وسط هذا كله فهو معتدله
وهذا وضع غريب بالنسبه له لكن
سيقرر موقف الرئيس
فعل اسرائيل وهذا سبب
الخطوات التي
يعني ربما لا يصف كثيرون خاصه في العالم
العربي نتنياهو بانه معتدل ولكن مقارنه
ربما من جفيرا اصبح البعض يراه معتدلا
وسؤالي لك هل الولايات المتحده والاداره
الامريكيه تحديدا سوف تصير على تغيير في
تركيبه هذه الحكومه ام هي فقط تريد النجم
بعض الممارسات التي تقوم بها الحكومه ولا
ضير في ان تستمر هذه الحكومه
بالمتطرفين والمتشددين الموجودين فيها
يعني
تقول وتملي على رئيس رئيس من يشمل في
حكومته ام لا هو لقمان لا يعني ان الرئيس
يمكن ان يقول للحكومه الامريكي
مناقشات حاليا حول طريقه همم هذه الحزبين
هل سيسمح لهما السفر المتحده للقيام
بالاتصالاتهم الرسميه
اعتقد الصوره الكبيره هي كل اللي تتعلق
بالديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه وهي الموضوع
الرئيسي في اذهان المسؤولين في واشنطن
والشعب الاسرائيلي وشكل هذه الديمقراطيه
وان الفريق يعني ذلك
وهم يرون ان الديمقراطيه مؤسسات القويه
ستكون امرا واضح ناقشينه مع رئيس
يودونا المحافظه على الديمق قضيهم و و
وهذه يكون لصالحهم وايضا و لصالح القضيه
الفلسطينيه هذا هو القلق الموجود حاليا
ولا يريد ان يصير يصير في طريق بديل او
تغيير الحكومات فهو فقد نحافظ على
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه استاذ معين اذا
يعني هل من اي تغيير منسود من خلال ما
نسمعه سواء من الاداره الامريكيه او
الاوروبيين وما هو الدور همم العربي الذي
يمكن ان يلعب لتكون هذه الضغوط فاعل لصالح
الفلسطيني
لا لا طبعا يعني اولا لو المحاكم
الاسرائيليه انصفت الفلسطينيين لما كان
هنالك في الضفه الغربيه الان مئات الالاف
المستوطنين والا ما اصبحت الارض
الفلسطينيه عباره عن جزر منفصله بحكم وجود
المستوطنات وانتشارها هذا في الحقيقه يعني
ما قاله ضيفك هو نوع من العراق اما فيما
يتعلق
نعم واشنطن قلقه من الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه ليست قلقه من الديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه اتجاه الفلسطينيين هذا شيء لا
يعنيها ولكن هذه المره حكومه نتنياهو يعني
اصبحت كعبه في الديمقراطيه في داخل
المجتمع اليهودي ذاته وهذا هو ما يثير قلق
واشنطن على ما اعتقد
شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لكما كان معنا من عمان معاينه طاهر
الكاتب والباحث الفلسطيني ومن واشنطن
جوينج روفر نائب المساعد السابق لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا
ناتي الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
واليك
[موسيقى]